سانجي ، أنت جراح أعصاب بطلة تلفزيونية
وأيضًا مؤلف كتاب بالإضافة
إلى كل ما
كنت ابنًا مخلصًا وأعرف
والديك ، لقد
حاولوا الحصول على اللقاح وكان من
الصعب عليهم الأمر الذي يوضح
مشكلة تحدث في  الولايات المتحدة
الآن ، نعم ، أعتقد
أن 17 مليون لقاح تم
شحنها في هذه المرحلة
شيء من هذا القبيل ولكن تم إعطاء أربعة ملايين لقاح فقط ،
وهناك
فجوة كبيرة لا تصل هذه اللقاحات إلى أحضان
الناس
وأنت وعائلتك  لقد
رأيت 15 مليون جرعة
وزعت 4 ملايين
في السلاح لكنك رأيت مباشرة من
خلال
والديك التحديات ، نعم لا هذا
رائع جدًا وأعتقد أنه يستحق
فقط تذكير الناس بهذه الأرقام
لأن المشكلة الحقيقية
هنا هي عدم التوزيع
مدى توفر اللقاح ، هذا شيء
سنستمر في العودة إليه ومناقشته
ولكن نعم أنت تعلم أنه مثير للاهتمام
والداي يعيشان في مقاطعة لي فلوريدا ، لذا
فلوريدا  عدد معين من
اللقاحات ومن ثم يتم
تخصيص اللقاحات لمختلف
المقاطعات ، ثم تقرر المقاطعات بشكل أساسي كيف
سيحاولون الحصول على هذه اللقطات في
أذرع الناس ،
وقد يتعامل ميامي
دايد مع الأمر بشكل مختلف عما قد يتعامل معه بروارد بشكل مختلف عن لي
المقاطعة ، حيث يعيش والداي ، على
سبيل المثال
، حصلوا على عدد معين من الجرعات في المقاطعة
، وما قرروا القيام به هناك
هو أخذ الجرعات ونوعًا من
توزيعها بين المباني العامة المختلفة ،
لذلك ذهب والداي على موقع Google
بحثا عن أمي حازمة جدًا
وقد قالت بشكل أساسي حسنًا ، لقد
اكتشفت أن مكتبة مقاطعة لي
ستبدأ في التطعيم
في الساعة التاسعة صباحًا هذا هو
الأربعاء الأخير الآن
الساعة التاسعة صباحًا ولكني
أعلم أيضًا أن لديهم 300
جرعة وهناك الآلاف  من الأشخاص الذين
يريدون هذه الجرعات ،
لذلك كان عليهم أن يصطفوا في طابور آه ووالدي
وصلوا إلى هناك
1 30 في الصباح يصطفون
بالخارج وهؤلاء هم في الأساس أشخاص فوق
سن 75 لأنهم  هذا هو من في هذه
الشريحة الأولى
وانتظروا حوالي تسع
ساعات للحصول على
لقاحهم وسأريكم بعض الصور
لاحقًا في الأسبوع لما تبدو عليه هذه السطور
أه والدي حيث تبين من 300
جرعة هم  تم إعطاؤهم أرقام التذاكر هذه
التي تقول 288 و 289 نجاحًا رائعًا ، وفي النهاية
تمكنوا من الحصول على اللقطة الأولى من
اللقاح ، لكن من المذهل أنه
كان مثل التخييم في
حفلة موسيقية ميتة ممتنة أو
شيء من هذا القبيل باستثناء حقيقة
أن
يزيد عمر الوالدين عن 75 عامًا ، ولديهم
ظروف موجودة مسبقًا ،
ومن الواضح أنهم مضطرون إلى البقاء متباعدين
، وكان عليهم الاحتفاظ بقناع عليهم ، وكانوا
قلقين بشأن الإصابة بالجفاف ،
فالأمر ليس شديد البرودة في فلوريدا ، لكنه
كان لا يزال باردًا بالخارج ، لذا فإن
كل هذه الأشياء  ما هو نوع ما
يحدث حتى يتم
تطعيم الناس في بعض الأماكن في أماكن أخرى ،
فقد سارت الأمور بشكل أكثر سلاسة ،
لكنها متفاوتة للغاية عندما تنظر في جميع
أنحاء البلاد